For now, let's assume everyone's friendly. There are lots of ways to do
this. And building a robust scale of a web service is challenging. For now,
what we're just going to do is set up a simple service running
on our own machine. Depending on how your machine is set up, and your
internet service provider, you might be able to create a server that other
people can use that way. But we're not going to get into that now.
If you do want to learn how to build a scalable, robust, externally
hosted web service. Which I hope many of you will. I would strongly encourage
you to take Steve Huffman's course on Web Application Engineering
which is all about how to do that after you've finished
this course. But, it turns out that setting up a
simple service running on our own machine is surprisingly easy. We're
going to do this by using a tool called web.py. Despite
being simple and small it's still quite powerful. It was originally
built as the web application framework to run Reddit. To install
it all you need to do is use PIP which hopefully
you have installed from unit nine. If not go back to unit nine
to see how to install that or follow the links here. And install
it like this and now we have the web module available to test
in Python. Next I'm going to go a little bit backwards from what
we usually do. I'm going to show you all the code that we
need to get our search engine running as a web application and then
I'll explain some parts of it. But I think you can figure out
a lot yourself and please try and do that. So here's all the code.
We're importing web.py. If you have the search engine
code and you download this code, and you've installed the
web.py module, you should be able to try this yourself
and see that it actually is running a web service
on your own machine. This code is in a
file we'll call server.py. Then we construct the web server
in a terminal by running python server.py, and we'll see
that it prints out that it's listening on port 8080.
And it's still running. Note that we haven't got a
new terminal prompt yet. So let's try using a web
browser, to see what it's doing. And here, you can
use any browser you want; we'll use the Firefox browser.
And we're going to make a request to the localhost.
So we'll make a request to our local server, we
can get to the localhost by doing all zeroes or
we could do localhost. And the port number, 8080. And we
send a request. We can see the server
printed out a message, told us something happened. And
that's done by the web.py code. It's telling us
that we got a request. And we got a
response none. We could do a more interesting request. This time I'll use
localhost. And after the server and port.
We can put the key word wer'e searching for. So let's search for hummus. And now
we actually see the response from our lucky search. This
is the response we get for hummus. If we try
another keyword that doesn't exist in our index and we
get none. You can see in the log, the two
requests that came in and one was a get for
hummus. One was get for wisdom. So if you've got
that working, you're running a web server. You're running a
web application that responds to queries. We're not going to
deal with the complexities of making a nice form and
providing a pretty output in this class but you've got
the basic functionality of a web server up and running
and you can do searches by putting them in the URL.